déjà moi j'agis une perversée sur
moi-même en faisant ça c'est à dire que
je me protège pas trop entre mais je de
manière très très volontaire
au moment où on joue
je me présente je m'appelle Henri non
Virginie Efira
actrice dans un film de Valérie Douzi et
qui s'appelle l'amour et les forêts dans
lequel je joue de rôle de jumelles
blanches et rose et blanche va se
retrouver exposer d'abord à un grand
amour qui va très vite devenir un grand
enfer
que c'est arrangé pour me rendre la
fille comme possible il vous suivez
[Musique]
vous
à la moindre de mes questions
[Musique]
je vous préviens le chemin va être long
on devrait dire des choses qui font
souffrir c'est une guerre
[Musique]
plus que de jouer sur la vulnérabilité
ou la faiblesse ce serait pire encore du
personnage de jouer sur sa solidité de
sa force c'est à dire il y a quelque
chose ou même si on est fort planté
solide
actif etc il y a quand même quelque
chose qui peut finir par vous dominer
[Musique]
on parlait pas au pénal avant de du
terme d'emprise aujourd'hui on peut pas
être inculpé pour emprise ça n'existe
pas mais c'est sorti du langage et du
vocable des des fraudiens des
psychanalystes et de la psychologie pour
dire il y a parfois des gens qui ne sont
pas conscients de ce qu'ils sont en
train de de vivre et que le film aussi
mette un accent sur les violences
morales et psychologiques aussi
c'est quelque chose qu'on a pu
s'en rentrer dans un témoignage sur ma
vie intime et fréquentée quand même un
peu
il y a quelque chose d'assez chouette je
pense pas que le cinéma puisse pas être
un acteur une chose thérapeutique mais
tout d'un coup quelque chose de un peu
particulier qu'on aurait pu vivre on en
fait une utilisation
concrète elle en fait quelque chose on
retourne à l'intérieur de quelque chose
où on se dit tiens qu'est-ce qu'il fait
que cette chose là qui est dure on
n'entend pas qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on se
lève pas pour partir qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on reste à quel endroit se passe
quand même la croyance est-ce que c'est
de la faiblesse ça non c'est une grande
solidité aussi donc ça permet de de
voyager à l'intérieur de soi et c'est
quand même aussi très intéressant